octopuses are the weirdest animal on
earth and I know what you're thinking is
it because they have three hearts or
blue blood or that they can regrow their
limbs or that they're known to use tools
or they can change colors whenever they
want and of course all that is pretty
cool but it's just the beginning
turns out octopuses and their clothes
colloid relatives have a unique ability
to edit significant amounts of their RNA
and they've been doing this long before
modern humans showed up on the scene
about two hundred thousand years ago
while scientists aren't sure how or why
it started studies suggest that
octopuses today are editing their RNA to
adapt to temperature changes in their
environment RNA is sort of like DNA
editing but in some ways even better but
what makes RNA editing different from
DNA editing is the long term effects
your DNA for instance is identical in
each one of your trillions of adult
cells so changing the code in one cell
changes it forever and it fundamentally
alters your genome which is passed down
to your children and every generation
thereafter and this is how the majority
of the animal kingdom evolves but
octopuses do things differently by also
editing their RNA this allows them to
try out adaptations in the short term
without messing with entire generations
to come without damaging the master copy
of your genetic information unlike DNA
changes to RNA are not hereditary it
also means you can target certain body
parts and edit the RNA in them
individually in fact research groups
have discovered the
octopuses tend to edit the RNA in their
brain tissue more than anywhere else
which has led some experts to
hypothesize this is why octopuses are
the most intelligent of all
invertebrates in the planet now
most organisms including humans have the
enzyme necessary for RNA editing but the
general consensus is it's just not worth
the effort humans for example have
around ten RNA editing sites but
octopuses have tens of thousands so
octopuses and their colloid cousins
truly are bizarre but it may not be the
case for too much longer scientists have
recently proven ways of using CRISPR to
edit RNA too perhaps they can learn a
thing or two from the experts
[Music]